what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
hey everybody welcome back to on wax
to another tuesday thanks for tuning
back in with us we are happy you're here
did you have a good start this morning
because um if i'm not mistaken
you've had a rough start to the morning
with your car
yes i currently have my car door handle
in my purse right now
um i won't get into the logistics of
that but i was
i am covered in tire grease yes she had
to
we were looking it up online trying to
figure out how to get this car to
actually lock since her
key battery died but now like quarantine
is making me a dumber person
like i just can't figure out we did
figure it out we did figure it out we
have your door handle and the car is
locked so we did figure it out but whoa
do you hear that voice cracker
you're going through puberty i know
that's so cute well actually the thing i
did this week kind of treated
was like a teenage boy we'll do our
walks in wayne then right now okay let's
start it off so hi i'm tan
bronze we just come came back from tulum
oh god just rub it in everyone's faces
what do you mean
i'm relaxed and zen no
but and i mean we can get into that a
little bit after
but low so i don't know if you do hold
on
backtrack no your high is that your tan
and bronzed and blonde
yes what about it i just feel confident
i feel good
i look hey you know what i'm owning it
my hair is long i've been cutting in a
while
but this is my low um i don't know if
you do this but
i i shave my face
do you shave your face will's nodding
his head i've heard about this
okay removes like a skin layer yes that
i shave my face too because if i didn't
i'm pretty sure i could grow a handlebar
mustache okay so i just realized also
this morning i'm like i need to pluck my
mustache but
this is bad so i was starting to use
this like little shavers new
i'm trying to get all the peach fuzz off
trying to get the dead skin off
and then while i'm shaving my neck like
a pre-pubescent boy
i cut myself oh that's bad
of my neck and it wouldn't stop bleeding
and now i just have this
scar or scratch yeah i don't know what i
was doing wrong
i don't know if my angling was wrong but
i had to keep like
toilet or tissue paper there and i was i
looked in there i'm like
i look like my daughter i don't know why
i have this vision in my head right now
with you
like covered in shaving cream like oh
yeah that's the thing is i was kind of
doing that because i was trying i'm like
okay i can't just like
do it without anything on so maybe i put
like lotion items on anyone that knows
how to actually do it you're probably
freaking out what i did but
i'm pretty sure my wayne is worse than
your wayne
what's wait so what's your high though
we'll start off in the high point
are y'all ready for this yeah i have a
date
oh cece has a day
there we go reverse sofia you're not the
only one
out there in the dating world i have
been absolutely single
hardcore single cysteine has been
thriving
well let me tell you why i feel like
i've been manifesting
a certain type of guy for a very long
time
and i say yes to everybody every single
time i'm with a friend
i'm with my neighbor with anyone i'm
like
you got any singles you got any guys
these are what i like
anyone and now all at once all in one
week i'm getting she blasted her
dating resume for months yes and months
and
now i also have to say my zodiac for
this month
don't roll your eyes it said for the
past six months every single day
trouble with sex and love and
relationships
for six months well six months mine was
every month is great
it said i'm thriving in those areas mine
said the opposite it says i need to go
inward
and look at myself that sounds boring
boring but
what are you guys doing i don't know oh
fun
it's kind of one of those things where
it just got set up and we
have not talked since but guys this is a
man he's not a boy
he's mature he has a job he's gonna take
it but let me tell you
about my wayne that kind of puts a
damper on all of this
um tmi please don't check out after you
hear this
but your girl got a little case of the
uh not covet
of the montezuma's river
all right all right alright i got
montezuma's revenge have you guys ever
seen that
stop have you ever seen i'd like to
think of it as if i'm in sex in the city
do you remember in the second movie when
they're all in was it mexico
were they in mexico the first movie was
it great when big left her
yeah and they went on her honeymoon and
she opened her mouth drank the water
yep that was you yeah cesine's stomach
has been hurting for the past
week i've been fine but i feel skinny
you're the worst don't please just don't
tell them that on your date you don't
need to yeah no to be that's what i'd
like to open up with hi i have the shits
what's your name
let's just talk about talon but actually
we can just go into talking about tulum
that was
awesome oh yes we did a little bit of a
escape but it was very very isolated
like we were not in the part of tulum
where there was people around like this
hotel was maybe
yeah 10 ma occupancy like there was no
one
we did it right we got tested before we
got tested when we came home
yeah we took every precautionary measure
it was but it was really nice and that's
why
i was like i'm blind and i'm broke
because we didn't move every single day
we didn't go to a party
we didn't barely went to dinners it was
laying on the beach for 12 hours and
drinking and drinking
that was it it was great
and now we're back here and we're in our
house no but we are really
excited to bring on this guest and i
know we say that
about every week and every guest that we
have
but this is one that we've had talking
about no we've been talking about this
guest and this topic
since the beginning of when on wax was
born yes when we were trying to
write up a list of people this person
was on our list this topic
we're so excited so we're just gonna
bring her on because we can't
wait another minute sex baby and now
we are about to announce the winner of
the salt
water luxe competition
avi niesel congratulations girl abby
your instagram is
a b b e y underscore n e i
s e l congrats abby spend your money at
saltwater lux
i can't wait to see you sporting the
clothes and thank you for supporting our
podcast
we love you love you hey everyone
we have to talk about something what
hangovers oh god
we hate those you know being young in
your 20s we love to have fun right
sophia we like the occasional
tequila every night you know but we hate
the consequences
that come with drinking alcohol so we
are so happy that we found a product
that makes you feel better and stay
healthy when you drink
i'm totally serious this changes your
life you guys
cbd talks it is a cbd based hangover
remedy that targets
the physical and mental aspects of a
hangover cbd is a natural
compound found in hemp so it makes you
feel calmer alleviate pain nausea and
gets rid of toxins in your body yeah
there's all natural antioxidants like
electrolytes vitamins
detox agents to help you feel better and
to help your body recover
faster i just want to make sure you guys
know that it has zero percent thc so it
won't give you that like
high feeling anyways you guys they're
really cute they come in this
blue and white gel you take one to two
capsules it's super easy
so i'm gonna tell you guys how you can
get on this amazing offer
right now we have a special 20 off
discount for you
go to shop.getcbdtalks.com
that's talks shop.getcbdtalks cbdtox.com
and use code
unwaxed at checkout they offer a 30 day
money-back guarantee so you have nothing
to lose trying it out
again go to shopgetcbdtalks.com
and use code unwaxed for 20 off you can
also find them on instagram at
cbd talks remedy let us know what you
think cause it certainly helps sophia
and i
so i definitely want to hear if it helps
you guys
also known as the dildo duchess
this lady is the ceo of an online
educational sex toy store called
spectrum boutique
co-host of her own podcast called hot
brain love that name
and author of the newly released sex
education book called cardinal knowledge
please welcome sex educator zoe liggin
thank you so much for having me it's a
pleasure to meet finally no we are so
excited you are here and you're
beautiful i was just like when you
walked into the room
like you're so pretty i've already like
watched all your videos on youtube but
impressed and i was like
you know i actually have a full face of
makeup on which is a rarity no
don't call it the world it's so it's no
natural natural this is the way it
always we
lied we literally wake up in the morning
so i want to jump
right in and talk about your new book
cardinal knowledge
yeah so tell us what can we expect from
this book
so this is a collaboration with my best
friend elizabeth renstrom i've known her
over 10 years now but she is the
photographer uh
photo editor at the new yorker right now
um
we met working at american apparel in
2010.
by the way american afro was so cool it
was hot
it's awesome back in the day yes um
but this is like psas or public service
announcements that i think everybody
should know about sex
and it covers a wide range of subjects
but each page is one topic
so oh i like that you know nothing is a
huge deep dive on anyone's subject
matter but it's
supposed to kind of get the wheels
turning plant a little see
different subjects and it says sex
education you didn't get in school
yep because this was for me because i
remember
sex ed i knew nothing i remember
actually figuring things out like when
someone would say oh yeah i popped my
cherry like i was a sophomore in high
school and i was like oh yeah i do that
like every weekend
i have no idea i thought a blow job was
literally blow
i thought i thought like that as well no
but it's just like i i didn't learn
anything so it's it's really nice that
these books exist today
because finally we need to educate the
youth have you been getting a ton of
responses from that
yeah it came out like exactly a week ago
and it's been really lovely in that it's
also kind of a coffee table book you
could just
if you want right it's unintimidating
but you could also read a cover to cover
if you want
um it's super surreal to see my book
like i know it's physical forms yeah
like a favorite chapter of yours ooh
that's a hard question i like a lot of
them
one of that i think is an odd fave is
the foreskin page which is
something that in the united states we
are not ever talking about yeah because
like the average person does not have
foreskin
but in every other country except uh
muslim
uh israel muslim countries israel etc
like everybody else has foreskin right
is only normalized in the united states
i know when you hear about it here
everyone's like
they have that or like what do you do
with it like what do you how do you mess
with it like
it's it's so on it's foreign to
everybody and that's i think it's so
important that we know
i mean that it's normal and it's like
everyone no i
love it love that you're normalizing
this taboo
conversation so i kind of want to go
back and sort of dive into
what made you sort of a connoisseur and
sex talk sex toys and like what made you
want to be vocal about it
definitely i was making porn art when i
was 18
cutting up old magazines and like making
collages and stuff oh that's such an
aesthetic around the same time as when i
found sex toys because i'd been having
partnered sex
starting when i was 14 and then it
wasn't until i was 19 i got my hands on
a vibrator
and i realized oh i've never had an
orgasm before you're like a whole movie
exactly and like vibrators are just like
any other tool in the world
they like yes you can use your hands and
do this thing but here's a device that
will help you
you know bridge the gap if there is one
make it certainly a little bit more
attainable if orgasms are just out of
your reach and they certainly were for
me
so well people think i feel like people
assume that
with that people you're just supposed to
know that you will like instantly put
your hand on there and it's like
everything's being figured out i'll have
an orgasm and i'll figure it out but
these toys help people get to that point
know okay i actually can
climax i can do and i don't need someone
to do it for me
definitely i mean i was having sex that
was only informed from
like porn and non-pornographic movies
right i think that something i've been
aware of so much more is how
the movies i saw growing up really
brainwashed me to see
love and romance a certain way that's
actually pretty toxic
like right even going back to cinderella
i mean yeah
disney's really huge break it down a
hundred percent
so i think that is a perfect segue into
like talking about
masturbation definitely because a lot of
my girlfriends and even some guys
they're like oh and they're pretty open
about it they go i just have never done
it and they're in their early 20s or
mid-20s
and they say they feel uncomfortable
it's weird for them so
if you could give those people some
advice to maybe
how to start definitely i mean that is
not unusual at all it doesn't matter
what age you are
there's people who are middle aged and
beyond who have never had an orgasm or
touched themselves or even had partnered
sex
right and for me it was like i didn't
enjoy
the sensation of my own hand on my body
that's not true for everybody but i was
like
that and sometimes it's a trauma route
sometimes it's just like
right your body works but for me a
vibrator was literally like
okay i can directly interact with this
thing that
directly interacts with me and even
since then i've changed the way i
masturbate
so much that our sex lives are always
going to be changing
and it does take a lot of patience for
all of us and trial and error and even
finding the things you don't like will
help you find the things you do
i totally agree so what would you
recommend would be a good
starter vibrator that's a great question
and also a trick question because it
really just depends on the person
right of course i think a good rule of
thumb is pick something versatile
because for instance if it's a vibrator
you could use it externally or
internally not just something that's
only for external for instance you're
just gonna have more options
so if you don't like using it one way
there's another way
i've certainly gotten toys where i'm
like nope this is not for me and right
you know you can't return them
you can put them on your mantel there
you go i have lots of those on my mantel
for sure
and uh definitely experimentation
try different categories i feel like
people don't realize the health benefits
that are also behind masturbating and
almost
when you once you embrace your sexuality
and you have that orgasm then it's that
what do you what are like the benefits
behind it do you know specifically god
uh i'm certainly no doctor but it is
definitely
stress relieving you are just like
dumping
uh endorphins into your system i mean
just like
how exercising makes you happy uh so
does masturbating and pleasure
stimulation
even if you're not having an orgasm even
the journey there is just
really good for your heart it doesn't
want that yeah so actually i actually
googled it this morning
and so studies have shown that it
reduces stress increases relaxation
increases focus and concentration aka
post not clarity yeah helps alleviate
anxiety with that being said
why do you think the act of doing it is
so
intimidating because i feel like oh my
god this sounds great it's free you can
do it any time of the day you can do
multiple times in a day
and it's like you don't need to like
smoke to get this effect you guys
get it on your own yeah why do you think
it's a little bit like
i don't know it's very just a sensitive
topic yeah why is it not spoken about
enough
i think on one hand you have people who
are like oh if you're having if you're
[ __ ] enough then
you don't need it no you're laughing but
i created that you're like oh
oh my i've heard men say oh i don't need
to do that because i get it in other
ways yeah and it's like you could be
having all the sex you want and
masturbation is just a beautiful thing
to complement it
um or just do on its own you learn so
much more about your body
right you're masturbating and if you do
want
to have partnered sex it just makes it
that much easier to communicate to a
partner
yeah i think the stigma comes from a lot
of things
i think religion is one big component
even if you're not religious
totally it's like all around us not so
much in california but i live in the
midwest
oh yeah it's you know a little bit more
conservative
i mean but you still run into people
wherever you are la new york there's
people who are
totally still getting those messages
from the environment that it's sinful
shameful and i have my friends that
aren't even that religious that have
parents that just never taught them or
weren't comfortable enough to say like
oh
you can do this this is okay and so
they'll never get into it until their
friends maybe say oh
try this out and some people don't even
get to that point until like
way later and they're like oh god i
never got to actually experience that
with myself i mean
it's never something you can not do like
you can do at any age but
i think it's almost better to start
earlier or when you're
i don't know i guess in your 20s or
teenage years yeah i mean
this is so taboo to talk about but like
from birth
there is this exploration like babies
and i'm not saying
that sex education isn't something you
have to be aware there's age-appropriate
sex education
and the most basic fundamental building
block of that is like bodily autonomy
so there are aspects of sex education
that don't directly concern sex that
like we do pass on to the people in our
lives
and i don't think it is solely a
parent's job i mean i don't think
i'm not saying that a parent should
teach their kid to even masturbate it's
more just like
do they feel welcome to ask you the
questions when exactly does arise
yes yeah and it's a lot of one-minute
conversations instead of one big
long conversation over time you know
what's the difference um
between boys and girls like what are the
like the percentages
of masturbation because i know men are
way higher obviously than
girls and you may think that but we're
actually so much more alike yeah
we really like that i think that if you
have a penis
uh the the fact that it's external you
can see it with your own two eyes
there's
a lot of scientific research on
sexuality
concerning a penis the structure of the
internal clitoris was only
fully understood in the mid 90s
so oh my gosh i know we've understood
penises for
all of humankind and also in 90s
it doesn't help that to have like
internal
anatomy you can't see everything without
a hand mirror or just talked
very nicely inside like a cute little
package and how often are you
get a mirror and just like stare at it
like no one just thinks of doing that
scary itself
it's intimidating and that's your that's
your best friend she's there yeah yeah
meet her exactly hang out with her
figure out what she likes but i mean
again it has so much less to do with
gender and i think that there is this
idea that like men masturbate more
um i think that there's just a lot more
conversation about it
yeah and there's words for masturbation
but the
jacking off uh rubbing i mean but like
there's not as many for when it comes to
a vulva
like everything is kind of like jacking
or like wanking
or like yeah yeah i don't know i'm sure
it's like cultural wherever you are i
mean it's like oh there's always a trend
that someone's thinking of now that it's
just like yeah right
i feel like our sister was yeah in high
school it's like
the ways that you would describe like
hooking up with someone if you're like
oh we're hooking up
that means you're making up but my mom's
like wait they had sex like it's just
yeah it
always changes and then like to even
older people hooking up just means
hanging out
like my dad has to say oh let's hook up
later i'm like no no no
like yeah like does not mean hanging out
anymore
that is so funny you know i really want
to talk about orgasms yes that's been a
big
talk who doesn't like them we love the o
and i feel like they're so um
misunderstood or you don't really know
some people don't know how to get one
and some people like get them all the
time
or can he do multiple if there's so many
questions behind it so
to the basics how mental is an orgasm oh
yeah that's a great question i think
that
depends on the person for sure there's
some people who
can have like full body orgasms and
i know it sounds like a joke or whatever
but people who can just like
get a massage and orgasm i was watching
a documentary the other day and
i don't know if it's tantra or something
but the man wasn't even touching her
it was just hovering his hands over her
and she was orgasming
yeah i mean tantra is its own uh like
energy work
that's its own can of worms and i think
that
tantra is really amazing in that it
talks about energy work are you talking
about unwell by the way
okay no i'm really glad you brought that
up i thought that documentary did or you
know
docuseries whatever uh did a great job
of showing
the positive aspects and also the
predatory aspects of it
um i know it's also something that
people
really care about when it comes to
healing from trauma and sometimes that
is a really
great door into that world of your body
but that's something you can also do
at home right you're with a partner or
by yourself
i recently kind of made this metaphor of
how
for me at least vibrators were like a
metal detector
on my body like like it was like i
didn't know this spot was here
until i used the vibrator on it
that's actually a great way to put it
yeah because you put it everywhere and
then something will just click
i didn't notice that before i'm not
saying holding a vibrator randomly
on my for some people but
it is very mental it's very easy to
distract yourself
and like right uh and like of course
you'll be like think about baseball if
you don't want to like
the jokes like that but it is like so
easy to get thrown
off especially um like we're living in a
particularly difficult world right now
and nobody has the sex drive that they
did before i agree with that that's why
i'm thinking because
some women say they never had an orgasm
or they just can't orgasm that's why i'm
assuming maybe it is mental because they
can't focus and they can't just be in
the moment and feel the things they want
to feel
and it is hard when maybe like you've
had a preconceived notion of it or maybe
it's religion or
previous circumstances with past
relationships there's a lot
that can go into it but i want to talk
about faking an orgasm oh yeah because i
feel like
balls on it and we need to definitely
stop it
but my question is is it your partner's
responsibility
to give you an orgasm or is it your
responsibility um
i don't think it's anybody's
responsibility that's a good answer yeah
and if it happens
it happens and this is also yeah a good
segue from the last question and to this
is that i think because we define sex
typically and we're starting to change
this but it's typically
a penis in vagina intercourse yeah this
is what we see in film and porn uh that
type of sex works really well for a
penis not so great for a vulva
the vast majority of people need
external or external paired with an
internal
orgasm so for me at least it was like i
was just having penetrative sex
no [ __ ] action was going on it wasn't
until
yeah exactly and some people don't like
penetration and some people hate
external stimulation
right but even when you are having like
intercourse or whatever the [ __ ] can
still be
stimulated by your partner's like pubic
bones stomach
whatever so even the internal parts of
the vagina are still connected to the
[ __ ]
yeah and i think a lot of the time the
emphasis
is not being put enough on clitoral
stimulation but also including the
internal parts of the clip
do you suggest that for people that have
a hard time getting off that
they should just start there maybe if
they can't if it's hard for them to
climax with their partner
or yeah i mean whatever you feel
comfortable
doing i think statistically focus
externally because that's where most
people are
achieving orgasm from stimulation and
some people want to categorize
categorize orgasms like this is an
intern a uterine orgasm yeah i think
they're all the same
and you can certainly get there
different ways yeah
but there isn't one that's like better
or whatever
from the other they're all the same yeah
and like you
can like someone can use a vibrator on
you that's really hot but people
aren't used to seeing that it's like
guys get kind of
insane about it
but what do you what do you suggest for
someone like
if you want to go twice in one round for
example
is that possible for everyone else is it
sort of like a
your body depends is different from
someone else's body and they can't do
the same thing or is everyone
capable of doing it that's a great
question i keep saying that but no
you're really asking great questions
uh we all have like
not to use clinical terms but it's like
an orgasm
builds in desi like intensity there's
like the plateau phase where you're like
i feel like i'm on the precipice
yeah then you have the orgasm
and the refractory period but
basically the concept of multiple
orgasms is you're just kind of like it's
like a skipping stone
sometimes you skip a stone and it just
goes plop one time
right but sometimes you can just like
ride this roller coaster wave
um i think that a lot of factors depend
on how you get there
for me um i find it's easier with
partnered sex because then i have
somebody else encouraging me
to continue going yeah but it's
certainly possible alone
it's also quite meditative like a book
i'd recommend is called the
multi-orgasmic couple it's like
a bit of an older book but there's some
really good stuff
in there and it has a lot to do with
things that you probably saw in the
tantra episode of that show
yeah it's like circulating energy in
your body
and stuff that's like a little bit more
woo-woo than scientific but
that is how people describe that and
it's easier if you have a vulva but that
doesn't mean
it's not possible for everybody this
actually this is like especially this
question because i
when the way you explain like the
skipping the rock i feel like i've seen
so many shows where they go
i just had the most mind-blowing orgasm
and
some people are like oh it's like orgasm
is there like a difference or do people
just have like more of a
like people like i saw color and
rainbows and waterfalls while i was like
coming and then i
i was like i did like i don't even know
i just saw my bedroom wall
i was like my eyes are closed is that
is that possible i mean do people have
like is there a difference between like
an amazing orgasm versus like a good one
ah
that's oh you're making me think about
how
we're asking the hard hitting no you
really are educate us
i think that there's this certain uh
storytelling aspect when it comes to our
orgasms
like i know that i felt so pressured to
have an orgasm that i was lying about
having orgasms even to myself like i was
like i'm pretty sure that was one
yeah right because i didn't really want
to think about okay but what if i'm not
what does that mean
about me what's wrong with me if i'm not
having orgasms but that is like the
exact opposite mindset you want to have
if you want to have an orgasm right
um i think i've definitely had
there's an entire category of porn
called like ruined orgasm where it's
like someone
like destroying yeah but it's like haha
now i'm removing this too quickly or
something yeah
um but i think that there can definitely
be different intensities to orgasm
uh i think a certain aspect of it too is
just like
how you are engaging with the sex like i
think there's
like like in bdsm and kink there's like
subspace where you're
you're kind of like going into this like
literal like different
state of different brain waves and
you're just like in the zone
um and then there's some times where
you're just like in yourself by yourself
busting out an orgasm real quick like a
vibrator
i think that sometimes building up over
time
uh and edging can definitely help your
orgasm feel more deep and intense
but i don't know it's just kind of like
how eating the same meal on a different
day is going to hit different or yeah
the ingredients might be a little
different my girlfriend actually really
wanted me to ask this question to you
yeah um what about nipple orgasms are
those
real definitely is that does it vary
with each person
like i don't you know i've never had an
orgasm through my nipples that doesn't
mean it's not possible
i thought i'd never say it nipple orgasm
orgasm
here we are some people have really
sensitive nipples some people are like
do not [ __ ] touch my nipples
it's too sensitive really not sensitive
at all
i've had friends who've gotten nipple
piercings to make them more sensitive
and it has worked and i've had people
where it completely killed the sensation
in their nipples i didn't even know they
could
enhance it i've heard that oh i mean
that's why people get genital piercings
too
because it's like adding weight and
adding
an added sensation the texture of the
metal that would hurt really bad
i mean it's definitely not one i've got
a piercing gal myself but i know it's a
thing for other people
same thing with nipple play there's like
clamps
pumps i like the little like tiny twisty
pump things
right those are really fun um there's
just a ton of nerve endings there
and like your lips your genitals like
everything with the like mucus membrane
or like that type of skin texture
generally
uh even like our fingertips are really
sensitive but
uh you know it's far less sensitive than
your elbow or the side of your
arm it's just uh our ears then is that
another thing that why people get
started like trying yours for sure
yeah at this point i would say like i
feel like guys will face your
head yeah a lot of nervous there more
than your back which probably has the
leak
what i mean less than the face here's
the thing guys
the dream of having straighter teeth can
become
a reality for you it's one of those
things that we would love to do for
ourselves but just
haven't done it this is it you guys
thanks to candid straightening your
teeth is simpler and easier and more
comfortable than ever
candi clear aligners are comfortable
they're removable
they're practically invisible like
underwire braces so you can transform
your smile without
anyone noticing candid only works with
orthodontist
never general dentist like other
companies plus your supervising
orthodontist will be there with you
every step of the way the average candid
treatment is about
six months what you can start seeing
results way before then
and the costs are thousands less than
braces what you guys
come on candid if you're not doing it
i'm doing it even though sophie and i
have had braces
we wish we could turn back time and use
candid so start straightening your teeth
today right now
all my listeners can save 75 dollars on
candid starter kit so go to candidco.com
unwax and use code unwaxed that's candid
co dot com slash unwaxed code
unwax take advantage of this limited
time offer to save 75
on your starter kit candid co.com
unwaxed code unwaxed
so i want to sort of pick up on what you
had said earlier that
um people especially during this time
especially during quarantine
have been like very not sexually driven
whatsoever
so how do you keep it interesting
in quarantine age-old questions and then
part two how do you keep it interesting
in a long-term relationship yeah things
are always going to be
changing your sex drive will wax and
wane throughout your life
no matter whether there's a global
pandemic or not medication is a big
thing that impacts that also just
hormonal changes
the time of the month of the menstrual
cycle certainly affects it
um but just i think trying to see your
body
as something that you wake up to every
day and it's completely different you
are
going to greet each day differently and
what worked for you yesterday might not
be the same as today or tomorrow
right um that translates pretty easily
into
romantic relationships i've heard people
say it's like you have to re-fall in
love with your partner over and over
again
and there is definitely such a thing as
new relationship
energy that's a big word in non-monogamy
world because oh spitting because
get so into it it's impossible for a new
relationship
to not uh to to be like
feeling the same exact way as a
relationship you've been in for like
five years
it's just completely different and part
of the reason
a lot of people this used to be me i
would constantly be exiting and
re-entering relationships because i was
trying to get that like
thrill yeah it's impossible for that to
last forever but i sort of feel like
sometimes some ways that you can keep
that thrill
is to introduce new things and you know
sort of catch your partner off guard in
a good way like yeah dirty talk or a
role play
or bringing in sex toys so for like
beginners though
hypothetically let's say this is me and
i'm i'm
in i'm in quarantine with my boyfriend
and i'm bored and we don't really know
how to spice up our sex life like what
would you recommend
uh so many options i think that
long-term relationship check-ins are
awesome in any context
whether it's every two weeks every month
whatever
uh you might think you have nothing to
talk about but even when it comes to
like okay what are our relationship
rules oh we definitely have
always something to talk about yeah you
might find that like
oh we had never talked about this and
this is
you know maybe going to the strip club
not during covid i don't know if the
clubs are open again
but it's like yeah maybe you're both
really into that and
also things like that yes no maybe list
uh
you have basically a word bank of
different sex
acts you can do it like a kinky one or
like a very
vanilla one like it could just be like
blow jobs
foot massage or like maybe it's like
tickling or like
wrestling what if you're nervous to
bring this up to your partner because i
feel like a lot of girls sometimes or
guys
they just don't know how to introduce
that topic because some people are
probably a little bit more if you
haven't been that way let's say you have
that vanilla sex is fine
yeah i love it which is always it's so
sweet it's good but let's say you're
just like you know let's spice it up and
we're in quarantine
it's been like four years yeah how do
you introduce that without like throwing
them off thinking oh is our
sex life boring is it not enough use
this podcast as an excuse you can
literally be like
i heard these wacky people like blame me
blame it on me listen to unwanted
listen to zoey it's really um
i mean sometimes just saying like i'm
really nervous because we've never
talked about this before but like i've
heard a lot of people talking about this
let's do it
um i like to just make disclaimers like
that um
but yeah i i mean there's nothing wrong
with bringing something up out of the
blue i totally get like
even when it comes to introducing a
vibrator people are like we've been
having sex without a vibrator for years
why would you
need it worse but no i mean it's like
a fun new thing to interact with it's
just like
you know i'm always getting new
appliances for my kitchen even though i
think i have everything
you could have three hammers exactly
and if you want that like new
relationship hi this is something new
you guys haven't done before
that brings in the excitement even if it
doesn't work out totally well and maybe
like it takes a couple tries
yeah it's still something foreign so you
both aren't totally i feel like it's
nicer when you both haven't done
something before and that you get to
learn together it's a story and you guys
can like
oh like maybe that seems cool or like
maybe we could try that and it just
opens the door
even just to change a venue like go
camping or like right
i don't know there's it doesn't have to
be like a thing you go by
as you're saying it's like the location
the time of day the position
there's so many things that can add
variety and make
there be an element of newness in a
relationship that is old
right i love that so we actually asked
our listeners
you're coming on we have some listener
questions love it that we're gonna
hopefully you can just help these people
out bring it on so the first one is
is it possible to have decent sex with a
condom
my experience has been no but would love
to ditch my birth control and make him
wear
condoms oh great question and
definitely there's more benefits to
preventing pregnancy than condoms
stis you know it is the main protection
against
sexually transmitted infections
especially stuff like
hpv which causes cervical cancer but
right not gonna meditate on that
um i am a huge encourager of condom
usage i know that people
feel like ah what a bummer lube is the
number one thing you can do
to help it okay that was another
question
what would you recommend is like the
safest
you know there's latex in a lot of lubes
what would you say is the safest
most sensitive lube okay so you're going
to want to watch out for ingredients
in it people
tend to buy like astro guide or id glide
or like just cvs brands
uh pharmacies are starting to get better
lubes
uh there's definitely some that are body
safe at a pharmacy
um spectrum boutique my sex toy store
like we try to make sure
everything we carry it doesn't have any
like numbing agents or
parabens which are things that are
banned from cosmetics but not from lube
which is like going into your mucus
membranes let's avoid that
um it's not regulated the same way as
other things sadly so
um you're going to want to avoid
anything with a sugar in it
glycerin is a sugar that some people are
sensitive to
that's in a lot of lubes but if you're
not super sensitive it's fine
a lot of it is trial and error i have so
many different lubes in my
house uh all lubes except
things with oil in them are going to be
compatible with condoms
um so when it comes to putting lube on a
condom a lot of people are like well
there's lube on the condom already
you're like i don't need lube there's
something
quote unquote wrong with me trust me
like it is
for everybody yeah how do you introduce
luke so
i'm like trying to change up this
question to someone that you don't
really know it's like
it's a one-eight stand or someone that
you've been seeing and you're about and
you maybe have a problem
getting wet or whatever so yeah how
would you say oh like can we
do this yeah without feeling
uncomfortable without them feeling
uncomfortable
for me it was like i was having painful
sex and not speaking up about it it felt
like
a rug burn in my vagina yeah and
with condoms sex toys all of that it's
just gonna help reduce
the friction spit is not lubricant it is
spit
it's gonna work a little bit for like
two seconds and then it's gone
lube is like there's so many ways you
could pitch it to a partner
one really fun way is like i we have
such
awesome long sessions and like right
nobody
can have long long sex without
eventually needing the assistance of
lubricant i don't care who you
are if you lubricate in mass quantities
it says nothing about your body
that's so because that was one of the
questions and the girls was asking like
i have a problem getting wet
yeah and she doesn't know if it's her
fault or if she's like there's something
wrong with her but isn't it just some
people
are like that some people aren't like
maybe during your period of the month
yeah exactly medication stress
hydration there's so many factors are
you
having external stimulation like if you
have a cold
if you're like doing no warm-up and
you're just going for penetration like i
that makes my body tense up like yeah
that's nice
for play 2020 i mean that's how it is
shown in the movies it's just like
yeah passion
yeah she's like two seconds but like put
the lube
a tiny drop at the end of the condom not
just on the
outside the very tip it'll make it feel
better on a penis as well
so it's also going to reduce the chances
that a condom breaks now you don't want
to drench it in lube because then the
condom will come
off right if you put a little bit of the
reservoir tip
that is like in my opinion the benefit
of having that tip
besides you know catching calm or
whatever but it helps
the head not get so frictiony either so
it's really for everybody's benefit
right especially with condoms my last
condom tip because like condoms are so
important
latex free condoms transmit body heat
better
free like tax free i like the trojan
skin ones there's also ones called
unique condoms
and i think supra is another brand
perfect yeah those are good too go for
those
yeah i like it um so another question is
what is an underrated sex position oh
underrated something that people just
don't talk about enough oh my god
i mean i'm joking but i'm not like
missionary no i'm just kidding
uh no but i think there's some people
who are like this is so boring and i'm
just like i
[ __ ] love missionary sex or like like
you don't have to be
honestly it's like so uncomfortable
first like
everyone's bodies fit together
differently totally it's not going to
work the way you see it in the little
like position guide necessarily
it's totally fun to try out different
stuff i'm not saying don't do that but
don't feel like you're like
not adventurous if you just like are
going for the
the gold standard or like yeah that
classic 101
sex position i mean i think doggy style
is probably over
represented because of just like the
angling is not great for
the g-spot yeah that's what i was insane
because one of the girls wrote to us
that i remember she was saying about
doggy that she never gets
off on it and is there a way to make
that better
it's just like external stimulation
again this is my opinion but i think
that it's all about the view for the
penetrator
more than the way it's gonna feel for
the receiver totally
uh that's not true for everybody some
people's sticks curve down or sideways
right you know some people don't have a
curve uh
there's so many ways you could get
creative with it even if it's like
you're propped up on your side on a
table like doggy style can be
interpreted
interpreted so many different ways yeah
there are sex
wedges that are made by a company called
liberator they're like what is sex
wedge so it's like a like a tiny
triangle
uh or okay think about like orthopedic
pillows yeah yeah
it puts you on an incline and if you are
lying over that
it not only puts pressure on your
stomach so that when it's like hitting
the front wall of your body yeah it's
going to get more pressure on the g-spot
they're literally just pillows designed
to make sex more comfortable
and it's also great for disability
physical pain all of that jazz but like
i also just like to eat snacks on my
pillow
multiple uses the g-spot is like a
eureka
i did too and it's real wikipedia still
says the g-spot is fake
what and it's because it's not a spot
it's an area
that is part of the clip do you think we
made it up
i mean we're just trying to make it
harder for all guys
so just there's no funding for research
there's
a couple studies that people like to
point to and say look this is conclusive
evidence the g-spot isn't real
and it's all like men with like six
bodies being like like cold entry into a
vagina be like
nothing's there just like a penis the
[ __ ] gets erect
so if you are not aroused good luck
finding your g-spot
if you have not found your g-spot it is
anywhere from like one to three inches i
have a very shallow one so i was
searching too deep for a very long
time but there's like a it's like oh
okay i didn't even know that was a thing
either there's like adapters well how do
you know if you
you found it yeah okay yeah so it's on
the belly side
not my tailbone side so if i'm
stimulating myself i'm gonna be
pushing my fingers like towards my belly
right um
you can also feel like gutters on either
side
of it if your fingers are in your vagina
and you go all the way to the right or
all the way to the left there's like
these crevices
okay so you can treat that like the
boundaries of what you're searching
within
oh interesting so then as far as depth
goes the texture of it
feels like the skin behind your front
teeth back here
versus the skin in your cheek so it
feels kind of ridgy
and firm like little ripples versus just
like smooth tissue
and you can literally see your g-spot if
you get a speculum like they use at the
ob gyn
yeah uh but you turn it sideways
wow okay we're grabbing our mirrors
we're gonna go figure out how deep it is
honestly i
uh shot a video that has never been
released because it was right before
covid but it was like
me literally shooting footage of my own
g-spot
no yeah and i was like it was still even
weird too
are you going to post it one day only
fans maybe
why not i i mean i already have one i'm
just like
really yeah i just was like i don't know
if i wanna i was like trying to do a
series of videos yeah and then kovid
messed up my whole plan to do that
that we're like you can do like a
quarantine g-spot discovery type like
series on only fans i mean you can get a
speculum really inexpensively and then
all it takes is a hand mirror and lube
and you know be gentle on your body it's
not comfortable to put a speculum
ever but it takes a speculum and
encouragement and
enthusiasm yeah maybe a glass of wine
exactly even my good friends
uh who know me super well are still ner
like they're like i want to do this one
day but i'm not ready yet
and like that's totally cool like i
didn't want to
look for a really long time either i
think when it's sometimes like you tell
yourself the longer you've waited it's
like
uh i'll have to confront how long i've
been
not thinking about this right um and
that's okay
like nobody tells us how to do this
stuff again
certainly didn't learn in school but
yeah yeah
it's not your parents job to teach you
this stuff it is
all about having the space to explore
and feel safe
doing so and you know the tools along
the way as it becomes age-appropriate
so i feel like i could talk to you for
hours yeah
seriously it's a treat i'm so sad that
we have to wrap this episode up i know
but i want to encourage everyone to go
pick up her book cardinal knowledge
please plug all of your socials i am at
thongria like thong
ria on instagram
and my store for sex toys is
shop spectrum boutique on instagram shop
spectrum on twitter
and spectrumbt.com is where you can find
all of the
good sex toys that i curate myself so
perfect and check out her podcast hot
brains
yes i do that with my boyfriend which
you know oh it's so close
it's fun to you know work with someone
you love and it's
it's difficult too male perspective
always yeah thank you so much for coming
on
thanks so much from all of us here at
the show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts spotify or
podcastone.com
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at
unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week